éventrés par les bombardements russes
kharkiv est aujourd'hui une ville
méconnaissable
ces dernières 24 heures les frappes se
sont abattues en plein centre sur des
locaux de la police une université
et même une école
on distingue ici le lieu exact de
l'impact
dans l'une des artères principales un
secouriste filmé ces images
voilà le centre vive il ya beaucoup de
destructions
selon l'armée ukrainienne des troupes
aéroportées russes ont débarqué cette
nuit à kharkiv aucune image officielle
pour l'instant
dans la deuxième ville d'ukraine près
d'un million et demi d'habitants assiste
au déluge de feu depuis chez eux
impuissant
c'est très difficile moralement gérait
on a mal dormi
on a peur c'est risqué de sortir
beaucoup de civils ont été blessées ou
tuées ailleurs parce qu'ils sont sortis
projeter quelque chose dans les
décombres les secours évacuent des morts
mais il ya parfois des survivants
cette victime bouge encore ses bras
depuis des jours dans cette ville
pilonnée les civils se terre là où ils
peuvent ceux qui n'ont pas de sous sol
vivent désormais rideaux fermés on est
dans l'obscurité aux biens dans la
pénombre dès qu'il ne me faite le jour
parce que vraiment les lumières c'est
les marques où il faut tirer à 90
kilomètres de là ben baba
les charrues sont déjà dans les rues
ainsi ce qu'ils sont avec le drapeau
nous est devant nous la mairie est juste
à côté
au nord-est de l'ukraine l'armée russe
poursuit sa progression